hello distinguish Yale alumni leaders
university administrators and invited
guests especially the 40 representatives
from 25 different educational
institutions from 17 countries and five
continents welcome to our assembly which
is the 75th assembly today my name is
lisa chapman i'm proud to say i'm from
the class of nineteen eighty one with an
MBA from the School of Management and it
is my honor and pleasure is chair of the
Yale aya Board of Governors to welcome
you all today I want to first start by
thanking the our entire team led by two
alumni leaders chris walsh and Beth
Cheney also the Ayase Bob bond and ELISA
Masterson with the entire aya
professional staff and faculty and the
staff and faculty from the School of
Public Health which is celebrating its
hundredth year as a leader in public
health education research and practice I
personally want to thank you all for
coming today and investing your time as
alumni leaders for the benefit of the
University you're right sorry okay
pardon me I'm sorry for alumni Lee for
for the benefit of the University and
their alumni constituencies I especially
want to encourage you to engage as
deeply as possible in the full breadth
of what the assembly has to offer today
today and tomorrow focusing on today's
program which will be on the public
health at Yale and with the students and
faculty who are engaged in advancing
acknowledged in that area and tomorrow's
program will provide an opportunity to
focus on alumni leadership roles
programs and initiatives partnerships
with staff and to hear both from
presidents olive a and Dean Holloway
about important campus issues that i'm
sure you're eager to learn more about i
want to point out we have a change in
the schedule and in light of recent
campus events I would like to highlight
a change in fri
today's program the change is now the
aya update will begin at eleven-fifteen
to be followed by campus update with
both presidents olive a and Dean
Holloway and a slightly later lunch
beginning around one o'clock to
accommodate that session attendees will
all have a question card in your packet
and what you've received when you
checked in and please fill it out if you
have a question about current events or
any university matter the cards will be
collected prior to their talk and will
be given to the president and the Dean
on behalf of the aya I want to thank all
the delegates and alumni leaders for
their ongoing service to Yale tonight at
the Yale metal dinner and in our awards
ceremony on Friday evening will be
recognizing extraordinary extraordinary
Yale alumni volunteer leaders for their
sanding service to Yale on behalf of
Yale at this time I'd like to recognize
two exemplary alumni volunteer leaders
who passed away recently milu the class
of 96 a former aya board member and
president of the Yale alumni association
of New York where she led the resurgence
of Jana as a force in the New York
alumni community and she died early
earlier this year Connor Fay the class
of 51 who served as former chair of the
Yale alumni fund and helped establish
the Yale alumni chorus foundation he
received the Yale medal in two thousand
he passed away in march this year over
the last five years connor champion the
hall fletcher school park project and
asheville north carolina may their
dedication to Yale continued to be an
inspiration to us all now I would like
to introduce Chris Wallace with thanks
for her and Beth Cheney's hard work and
putting together today's program on
public health the remainder of the
plenary sessions will be introduced by
Chris and Jeanette I cough a heckuva
covitz thank you very much Chris
thank you Lisa good morning my co-chair
Beth Cheney and I want to welcome you to
the 75th aya assembly quite a milestone
as usual the first day of the assembly
is based on a theme and the members of
the aya board of governors were asked
for ideas for this theme Beth is a 1989
graduate of the school of nursing and I
am a member of the medical school class
of 1973 so naturally we thought about
all the health related challenges that
have recently occurred at home and
around the world during the past year
there was an outbreak of measles in
Disneyland that engendered a clash of
personal and religious freedom with the
health needs of the community Ebola
spread in Africa and engendered terror
in the united states where expensive
preparations were carried out for a
potential epidemic individuals were
quarantined and businesses were closed
because of fear a pharmaceutical company
raised the price of an existing drug to
treat toxoplasmosis in patients with
compromised immune systems such as
hiv/aids from thirteen dollars and fifty
cents to seven hundred fifty dollars
highlighting the effect of the market on
health on the other hand we have a new
Surgeon General the vector thei who was
a 2003 graduate of the Yale School of
Medicine and yale school of management
he co-founded a nonprofit organization
called visions worldwide which is
devoted to hiv/aids education in India
and the United States and then there is
the Pope advocating for the environment
and the poor so there is hope the
centennial of the Yale School of Public
Health is a seminal event
especially when so many of today's
pressing crises require a public health
solution it has been a joy working with
janette echo Vicks and the other members
of the Yale School of Public Health
Centennial committee who works so hard
planning this wonderful assembly program
we can't thank them enough the Yale
community is knowledgeable and
influential and we hope that you learn
new ways to use that knowledge and exert
that influence thank you for coming to
our 75th assembly to your health Yale
and public health in the 21st century
and now it gives me great pleasure to
introduce to you genetica Vicks
professor of Epidemiology and of
psychology director of the Community
Alliance for research and engagement and
deputy director and director of training
at the Center for interdisciplinary
research on AIDS a biography of
Professor echo Vicks and all the other
assembly presenters can be found in the
back of your assembly program please
join me in welcoming professor x
good morning on behalf of Dean Paul
Cleary and my colleagues at the Yale
School of Public Health it's my pleasure
to welcome you to your health Yale and
public health in the 21st century is the
culminating event in our year-long
centennial celebration the Yale School
of Public Health was founded in nineteen
fifteen by Charles Edward Amory Winslow
Winslow's is considered by many to be
the founder of modern public health in
the United States he defined public
health rather broadly as the science and
art of preventing disease prolonging
life and promoting health through the
organized efforts and informed choices
of society organizations both public and
private communities and individuals he
was a visionary recognizing even a
century ago the importance of
transdisciplinary collaboration and
innovation in addition to masters and
doctoral degrees in public health it is
said that Winslow instilled medical
students and others with a preventive
spirit as you will see today the Yale
School of Public Health continues to
flourish building on Winslow's
intellectual vision are the numerous
achievements of our faculty and more
than 5,000 living alumni who have gone
on to become exceptional public health
leaders and I'm so pleased you will hear
from many of them today I'm going to
take a bit of poetic license to say that
I believe cea Winslow would have been
proud of all that we've accomplished in
public health in the last century and
that there is much more to do to realize
his ideals
imagine a world where every child is
born wanted and healthy and to term
imagine a world where people young and
old have a deep sense of belonging and
can live in safety and to fullest
potential a world where access to
quality care for health and mental
health adequate food and physical
activity are indeed accessible to all a
world with no chronic disease and one
where acute infection can be quickly
disarmed a world where silos are
replaced by integrated systems and
policies and we work together toward
healthier and more sustainable
communities imagine a world instilled
with tolerance and peace public health
addresses all of these issues and more
today we have the opportunity to think
deeply together about what it might
shake to achieve this vision the writer
an environmental activist Paul Hawken
summarized my feelings about this quite
well he said when asked if i'm a
pessimist or an optimist about the
future my answer is always the same if
you look at the science about what is
happening on earth and aren't
pessimistic you don't understand the
data but if you meet the people who are
working to restore this earth and the
lives of the poor and you aren't
optimistic then you haven't got a pulse
what I see everywhere in the world or
ordinary people willing to confront
despair power and incalculable odds to
restore some semblance of grace justice
and beauty to the world public health
can
and should lead the way and I believe
that there are among many three
essential elements first we must ask
relevant that is important questions for
our time we must approach the answers
with scientific rigor and with
imagination and third we must leverage
relationships to achieve these successes
relationships not just to improve
healthcare but across all sectors of
society to improve health for example
addressing underlying social
determinants of health inequities like
education and economic development to
create and sustain the healthier
communities we envision we need a sense
of urgency we need evidence and
engagement political will collaboration
and charismatic ideas we need a
commitment to innovation and we need a
strong and deep Public Health endowment
so that we have the resources to build
and to sustain healthy communities today
promises to be a rich and exciting day
with discourse on cancer care to climate
change and geographic focus ranging from
promoting public health right here in
New Haven Connecticut to the global
refugee crisis with more than 60
presenters I'd like to think that we
represent among the best in science
practice art and advocacy all dedicated
to improving the health of the public
this assembly provides a wonderful
opportunity to highlight the Yale School
of Public Health during our Centennial
and the innovative collaborations among
faculty students staff community
partners and of course with you our
esteemed alumni I invite you to be fully
engaged and to bring your very best
ideas to bear in the discourse
throughout the
day as you see in your agenda following
a plenary session here there is lunch
and then two sets of smaller group
interactive sessions if you'd like to
skip lunch though I have made sure it is
healthy and delicious no chips or soda I
gotta warn you you can attend a historic
Public Health moment at Yale today the
kickoff of tobacco free yale and i
invite you to practice healthy meeting
practices by standing throughout the day
if you are interested and able i was at
a meeting in London a few weeks ago when
something like this went up and the
facilitator insisted that everybody
stand at the end of each talk to
everybody got a standing ovation it was
really it was fabulous and please get
the word out to those who can't be here
today in real time tweet away Michael
Moran this one's for you in closing let
me take a moment to provide brief
introductions of two of our featured
speakers this morning and and just
before I do that I also want to
acknowledge ms.martin were at one of our
esteemed alums who will be closing out
the day with the afternoon keynote but
this morning it's my honor to welcome
both dean paul Clary and dr. Peter
Singer both distinguished scientists
with Yale affiliations and maybe by
chance both Canadian later this morning
and just a short while you'll hear from
Dean Paul Cleary in addition to the
honors listed in your agenda book he's
an elected member of the National
Academy of Medicine an elected fellow of
the American Association for the
Advancement of science in nearly a
decade of service Dean Clary has
increased the number and quality of our
faculty or students in our endowment
ensuring that as he leaves his post at
the end of the academic year he leaves
the Yale School of Public Health on a
strong
foundation for the next century I am
proud to call him my colleague and so
very grateful for your support over
these many years excuse me and first dr.
Peter Singer he studied internal
medicine at University of Toronto
medical ethics at University of Chicago
management at Harvard Business School
and public health here at Yale dr.
singer is one of our most distinguished
alumni along with dr. Abdullah de our he
co-authored the book the grandest
challenge taking life-saving science
from lab to village as you can read in
the agenda book he's the recipient of
numerous honors and awards including an
appointment as the officer of the order
of Canada for his contributions to
health research and bioethics and
perhaps more importantly is the impact
of dr. singers work as we strive to
redress our most pressing global health
challenges we are pleased and privileged
to have dr. singer at the helm so please
join me in welcoming dr. Peter Singer
back to Yale
but the I just really want to say how
proud and privileged I am to be here
today it's a real honor to be back here
at the Yale School of Public Health I
wanted to particularly thank Jeanette
and Beth and Marta and and Paul and
everyone who's been involved in this in
this event and really to welcome all of
you here look forward to sharing some
stories of exactly what what Jeanette
was talking about and just one of the
things she was talking about was Twitter
there's my twitter handle it would be a
privilege to stay in touch with you
after this event I know we're not going
to be able to have the full back and
forth that we could have over the next
10 years if we do it over Twitter so if
you follow me I'll follow you and then
we'll be able to carry this on beyond
today I want each of you to think and I
understand there's a diversity of people
in the audience think of a professor
that really affected you raise your hand
if there's a professor that you remember
here at Yale who really influenced you
really affected the way that things
happen for you I see most people are
raising their hands for me it was Alvin
Feinstein who was a sterling professor
of medicine and public health here at
Yale and I learned public health from
alvin and from others here at the school
of public health but mostly what I
learned is how to think and what you see
on the slide is an example of of his
method of teaching people how to think
including me this came from a letter
that he wrote to me commenting on one of
the papers that I'd written while I was
here and so very grateful to him and I I
use this I could tell I don't have to
read it and I use this slide just to say
I think each and every one of us in the
room were strongly influenced by our
experience here at Yale and I'm very
hopeful that over the next two or three
days you'll remember those moments and
it will cause you to increase your
positive feelings
warm feelings towards Yale and that
you'll be able to show that in various
ways that are available to you too to
show that I don't think you can come to
the school of public health without a
CEO Winslow slide so here's mine with
exactly the same exactly the same quote
the definition of Public Health that
Jeanette showed the science and art of
preventing disease prolonging life and
promoting health and efficiency through
organized community effort I think this
is the shorter version of of what you
showed the longer version is is kind of
better and I just want to use this to
segue to Paul Cleary Dean Paul Cleary
who you're here from in a moment who I
had the great privilege of meeting last
night and Paul will tell you essentially
how the terrific students and faculty at
Yale and in the School of Public Health
are doing many of the things and
tackling many of the challenges that I'm
going to talk about as well so I want to
make a connection between the things
that I'm going to talk about and the
things that Paul will talk about so this
is the definition of public health of
cea Winslow I think this is the new
definition of public health this is a
slide that shows the 17 global
sustainable development goals that
replace the Millennium Development Goals
these were adopted by the united nations
this fall they start in 2015 actually
january first 20 16 to be exact and they
go to 2030 and you can see there's a
wide variety of of goals health is under
goal three but there's a number of other
goals hunger education gender clean
water and sanitation and in fact almost
all the goals are touched by health and
public health so what I think about
public health I think about these goals
almost now is the definition of global
public health and the contributions that
public health can make and in contrast
to the Millennium Development Goals
these goals are meant to be universal so
they're meant to apply to Cabarrus slum
in Nairobi and they're also meant to
apply throughout the unite
States so they can serve for us as a
type of as a type of guideline one of
the main points I want to make is that
innovation in public health social
innovation science and technology
innovation business innovation actually
accelerate how we can attain these goals
and underlying these goals by the way
there's a hundred and sixty nine or so
targets very specific numerical targets
under each for example rates of maternal
mortality rates of newborn mortality
that are meant to be meant to be reached
and one of the key points I want to make
is I don't think that those targets can
actually be attained without innovation
and so the focus of my talk is going to
be about how innovation broadly defined
can help us achieve some of these
sustainable development goals and
targets in health and in related and in
related areas and by innovation I mean a
broad suite of things and you'll see the
examples from social innovation to
business innovation to science and
technology innovation so that's really
my main point which is the world has an
agenda public health can really serve
that agenda and innovation in public
health and innovation where generally is
needed to achieve it but when i say
innovation it's not really for its own
sake innovation really is the highway
impact is the destination so what does
all that mean I think the best way
really to express this is through
stories so about the first half of what
I have to say is just a series of
stories of innovations that we've
supported through Grand Challenges
Canada and with partners in global
public health that are today influencing
the lives of people in low and middle
income countries I actually took this
picture in a classroom which had a
hundred young girls in it it was about
an hour and a half outside of Nairobi
and this was a classroom full of girls
and you see that little Nia booklet in
front of that girl so why are they
taking this pose first of all we had
people from the
NGO which is called xana Africa and I'll
tell you about that in a second
essentially doing health education
public health education in this class of
girls and this was the moment when the
health educator said put your hands on
your heart and say I am special and
after that incantation we had this
picture what this NGO is doing is
actually providing health education
including about sexually transmitted
infections domestic violence and other
things to adolescent girls but using the
platform of sanitary pads and menstrual
hygiene to do that Sonia is actually a
sanitary pad product in low and middle
income countries one of the issues
actually limiting education and all
kinds of social things is lack of access
to simple sanitary pads something so
simple would keep girls from school and
so on and what this NGOs and Africa does
is it has distributed sanitary pads to
10,000 girls through community
organizations in Kenya use that as a
platform for health education around
sexually transmitted infections around
domestic violence and it's also now
starting to switch to a social
enterprise model and they have in
addition to the ten thousand girls who
get the pads for free 5,000 women and
girls to whom they're selling the pads
at a very low and affordable cost to
make the model not only scalable but
also sustainable so it's a great example
this I think of Adolescent Health as in
women children and adolescent health
that really underlies many of those
sustainable development goals the
innovation of course is the social
enterprise model and the mechanism of
delivery which really just gives the
underscores my point that innovations
don't always have to be fancy science
and technology they can be important
social innovations that have important
impacts this is another story of
innovation also with adolescent girls
and others I found myself about 18
months ago
again about two hours outside of the
capital of Bihar the poorest state in
India the capital is called Patna and I
find myself in the essentially in the
classroom that you see there and the
classroom is filling up with people and
people are the ones that you see on the
left there and I'm asking myself who are
all these people that this class rooms
filling up with these are all people
that you see in the picture including
the two adolescent girls on the right
who want to be teachers who would be
dead but are alive as a result of
innovation they're people who had
visceral leishmaniasis a very rare
disease also called Cala as are and with
that disease the issue is that if you
can find the people with Cal as are with
visceral leishmaniasis you can give them
one simple treatment for seventy dollars
a single intravenous dose of a drug
called amphotericin and they survive if
you don't find them they die and so
these were all people who were found by
an innovative process that combined
three things training community health
volunteers who lived in the villages to
identify the cases taking the test for
visceral leishmaniasis and Calla as our
that previously had been validated on
serum meaning it had to be done at a
more complicated lab and validating it
on blood meaning you could do it right
there sitting on a stool in the middle
of a village and also doing some
research on contact tracing so what
those three innovations did together is
it pushed the screening program deep
into the village helping to identify
cases helping to save the lives of these
hundred people helping to take four or
five hundred thousand person districts
in Bihar from higher levels of cala as
are down to elimination levels and now
together with the government of india we
funded this group to tackle the next
five districts of 5,000 people so
another example combining actually a
pretty straightforward social innovation
of training community volunteers with a
technological innovation of validating
and existing blood tests
to save lives this is my colleague Carly
silver this is in a village in Nepal
before the earthquake representing an
innovation that we funded along with
USAID Gates Foundation Norway in the UK
and you see the little baby that she's
holding in her hands one of the targets
underneath that sustainable development
goal on health is to keep the newborn
mortality rate to a particular level and
one of the key causes of newborn
mortality that's death in the first 30
days of life of little babies like the
little baby that Carly is holding is
infection and the way the infection gets
into the little baby is through the
umbilical cord when the cord is cut when
the baby is born sometimes made worse by
certain cultural practices like rubbing
dirt into the court the innovation here
is called chlorhexidine which is a
simple component of mouthwash and it's
essentially an antiseptic and what the
innovation was was together with those
partners we funded JSI which is an
American NGO to help distribute
chlorhexidine the innovation was in the
service delivery model through
volunteers to 1.2 million to reach 1.2
million newborns which now has saved
over 7,000 lives of newborns so that
newborn baby that sitting there would
have a much lower chance of dying
because she received chlorhexidine then
she would have without that in fact for
every 200 applications of chlorhexidine
you save one newborn life so again an
example of innovation saving lives
improving lives in low and middle income
countries this is an example that shifts
a little bit from saving to improving
you know iron deficiency anemia is very
very prevalent among women and a key
cause of it actually sits behind the
deaths of women for bleeding from
bleeding one of the Communist causes of
women's deaths around
the time of delivery because if your
hemoglobin level is already low
obviously if you bleed your greater risk
it's also a key cause of of childhood
lack of development if you have
insufficient iron stores insufficient
micronutrient of iron and so what this
was was again a delivery mechanism this
is a social enterprise called lucky iron
fish that's in Cambodia and you know
normally you would distribute iron
tablets and that's an effective way to
do it but the tablets cause cramping
they're hard to take sometimes etc so
what this social enterprise did was it
took a block of iron and put it in the
cooking pot that people were using to
cook their meals and found that the iron
that leeches off that block of iron put
in the cooking pot is actually enough to
cut iron deficiency rates in half so
first they started distributing these
ingots of iron and they found that there
was no uptake people were using them
kind of his door stops and to hold up
their books and and so what happened was
this social enterprise lucky iron fish
went back into Cambodian folklore and
found this story of lucky fish so then
they started casting their iron in the
form of lucky fish which you see here
and the uptake dramatically improved to
the point where now this social
enterprise has actually sold seventy
thousand of these iron fish in
high-income countries through outlets
like burberrys and it cross subsidizes
distribution of ingots in a fish in low
income countries where they've also sold
but at much much lower cost another
seventy thousand fish and each fish can
reach about five people and so that's at
least 350,000 in low and middle income
countries people reached with a source
of iron that they didn't have didn't
have before so you're starting to get
the sense of innovation really driving
really driving impact now it's not
enough to save the life of a mother and
a baby it's a
tastic start but you have to ask
yourself what will happen to that baby
over time and a lot of our focus so far
has been on maternal newborn children's
survival and appropriately so because
there's about 6 million kids who died
under the age of 5 around the world and
just over 200,000 women most of them in
the developing world most of them from
preventable causes but you also have to
focus on what the life of those kids
will be like one of the most shocking
statistics I've come across is that one
in three children born in the world
again mostly in the developing world
fail to reach their full developmental
potential and Jeanette was talking about
imagine a world with full potential and
that's 200 million children and there's
no better way actually to make sure that
a poor country stays poor then just to
mess with the brains of the kids in the
first thousand days of life and then
they never reach their potential in fact
it's been empirically shown that their
wages will be lower their rates of
violent gun crime will be higher their
rates of depression and other non
communicable diseases will be higher if
they don't have full brain development
in first thousand days of life from risk
factors like malnutrition lack of
responsive parenting and stimulation
child maltreatment and so on so this is
part of a program that we launched
called saving brains and this is me in
Nairobi with a young boy called Israel
and Israel is at a preschool that's
funded by a social enterprise called
kidogo and the idea here is to bring
really high-quality pre-k education and
there's much younger kids here as well
to very low and low income settings this
is in the middle of a slum in Nairobi
really to safeguard the brain
development of these children to make
sure they're stimulated to make sure
they have good nutrition and food in the
early days of life so Israel had just
gotten there a couple of years a couple
of weeks before he was not really
interacting with the other kids it was
all
most impossible for me to get him to
smile you can see he's not smiling in
this photo and as I left he started
crying he's probably the only person
I've ever met that was crying when as I
was leaving most people are crying when
I'm arriving but but this is a good
example again of combining nutrition
combining child stimulation and I
followed up on Israel now it's about six
months later and Israel's much better
integrated with the other kids he
socialized he's playing and Israel will
have a better future as a result of this
social enterprise and as a result of
this experience again you know this is
not complicated but it is innovative and
the focus is on impact and these are the
types of innovations that really can
change the world and was slogging it out
innovation by innovation let me just
give you a few more examples and the
reason I'm doing this in stories I think
people really I think the story's really
matter and by the way as I'll show you
in a moment we supported about 700
innovations through Grand Challenges
Canada with a total of about 235 million
canadian dollars and of those 700 we're
scaling about ten percent or 70 and i'm
showing you about eight examples of the
seventy so there's a much broader suite
of stories there that i'm sparing you
from one of the other areas that we've
tackled is the area of global mental
health mental health constitutes about
thirteen percent of the global burden of
disease and I won't ask for show of
hands but I bet you that each and every
one each and every person in this room
is in some way touched by either
personally or in their family or in a
close acquaintance by a mental health
problem could be depression could be
anxiety could be serious psychosis could
be
drug and alcohol abuse etc or use but i
bet you it's very widespread in this
room i certainly know that that's the
case in in in my family well if you live
in a low and middle-income country and
you have let's say depression which is a
common mental illness you will probably
go undiagnosed you'll be stigmatized you
will not receive treatment any kind of
treatment and your life will just be
essentially ruined and if you have a
serious mental illness like
schizophrenia or psychosis you're likely
to be locked in a room chained to a tree
that's the current state of play of
mental health diagnosis and treatment in
low and middle income countries there's
about an eighty-five percent treatment
gap you have an eighty-five percent
chance of receiving no diagnosis and
treatment and only about a fifteen
percent chance of receiving diagnosis
and treatment so what can be done about
that at scale this is an innovation
called the friendship bench in Harare
Zimbabwe and this is a little bench that
sits outside a primary care clinic that
actually does talk therapy so there's a
lay health worker there you can't have a
psychiatrist on every [ __ ] because of
the shortage of shortage of psychiatrist
but it's a psychiatrically trained
actually community health worker and
they do essentially CBT talk therapy
cognitive behavioral therapy over about
eight sessions when people come to the
bench they diagnose people with
depression etc and they provide them
with talk therapy and the initial trial
that we funded showed that this
investigator terrific psychiatrist in
Zimbabwe called Dixon shavonda showed
incredible results these aren't the
exact numbers because he hasn't
published them yet but the the
difference is something like this if you
have the full friendship bench treatment
at six months you have a is sorry if you
have depression and you don't have the
full friendship bench treatment at six
months your chance of being depressed is
about fifty percent still if you are
depressed and you have the friendship
bench treatment
comes down to about fifteen percent that
is a huge difference in depression rates
prevalence in people's health and so
that's what he showed in his initial
randomized trial and now we're in the
process of funding him to take this to
scale working with the municipality of
harare so he's about to scale this to
14,000 people throughout harare and a
couple of little suburbs of whom about
11200 are expected to benefit in the way
I described so he's starting to get to
scale and that's an example of a very
simple mental health innovation and by
the way for kind of mild to moderate
mental health conditions like depression
talk therapy and and drugs are pretty
well equivalent as you get to more
severe forms of depression obviously
drugs start to get much more important
and obviously for psychosis they're much
more important but simple things like
talk therapy like this can have a huge
effect I mean think about that picture I
painted of what happens if you have a
mental health condition this is a woman
i met in haiti and she's in a rural
setting actually two women one who just
had a baby one who's a bit older she
this other woman was around 60 and had
kind of set a table with a beautiful
little flower on it what happened to
both these women was they had simple
epilepsy they had seizures and they were
undiagnosed in fact they were
stigmatized people thought they were
possessed by witches we had the
privilege of funding actually Partners
in Health Partners in Health affiliate
in Haiti called za meal asante that
opened a program essentially employing a
bunch of X priests or priests it seemed
to go and find cases of people with
seizures would count as a mental
neurological disorder depression etc
bring them to treatment get them simple
treatment these two women both were
identified through that process receive
very simple treatments that cost pennies
a dose and their lives have completely
turned around they now don't
seizures they're enjoying their lives
there's a huge difference that you can
make on simple public health problems
like epilepsy through these kind of
innovations in low and middle income
countries this program to date has
screened about 6,000 people or
identified about 6,000 people with
mental health conditions of whom about
2,000 more than 2,000 have had
improvements in their health this is the
last story I want to share before i zoom
out a bit and make some broader points
this is Misaki Kawai and Garrett who's a
scientist at meharry University in
Kampala Uganda and most of the
innovations I've shown you so far are
simple social innovations not science
and technology and that has to do with
timeline you know we're about five years
old so most of the innovations having
results are social innovations they have
results early we've also funded a wide
range of science and technology
innovations for example a rapid
diagnostic test for Ebola which which
dr. mazaki has developed so the issue
with Ebola now in the endemic setting is
how do you prevent outbreaks from
becoming epidemics the problem with
Ebola and the reason it got out of
control is there were several outbreaks
that then spread before they could be
stopped before the cases could be
isolated before now vaccinations could
be done to actually succeed in that
setting you need a simple test at the
very primary care level if somebody
comes in with fever you need to be able
to do a test to see if they have Ebola
not the thirty or forty dollar tests
that are used in the epidemic setting
that are based on DNA and RNA nucleic
acids but cheap lateral flow tests like
pregnancy tests that might cost a dollar
too that's what dr. Musacchio iyengar is
developing and this is the first African
based test for for Ebola there's kind of
a another test that's being developed
out of UK defense technology that also
seems very promising so a new tool for a
big problem that killed 10,000 people
and as was mentioned in the introduction
caused all kinds of social dislocation
so just stepping back from those stories
and I hope you get the idea of what
innovation can do in global health I
told you most of this about Grand
Challenges Canada already the only thing
I didn't tell you is that whole
portfolio of 235 million dollars of
investments the 700 projects if you
project them out to 2030 and model them
out it's estimated that collectively
they'll save three million lives and
improve 35 million lives so you can
really get results from investing in
innovation I now want to take a step
back and make some broader points very
quickly and then leave some time for
questions so this whole area of
innovation in global health really had a
watershed moment around 2003 in 2003
Bill Gates said I'd really like to bring
some more science into the area of
global health and global public health
and look back to the turn of the century
and a guy called David Hilbert who'd
established Grand Challenges in
mathematics and bill said I'd like to
use this same Grand Challenges method to
stimulate innovation in global health
and global development I was very
fortunate to get a call in late 2002 to
help and we were able to develop 14
grand challenges goals mostly around
vaccines and stuff they were published
in 2003 in science the Gates Foundation
ultimately funded five hundred million
dollars of 42 or 41 projects to tackle
those things that was about 12 13 years
ago and those ones were pretty science
discovery science oriented so they're
just starting to achieve results and a
good example of one of them would be a
project that infected mosquitoes with a
small parasite called will ba kia so
they don't transmit the dengue virus
dengue is a terrible disease that has
actually can be very severe in its light
form it's like the flu but if you get it
the second time it's a hemorrhagic fever
and it's terrible
and it has at the moment no real
treatment just a couple of vaccines in
the pipeline so this is a very
transformational approach to dengue and
then the Gates Foundation kind of
pivoted and said these 41 projects at an
average size of 10 million dollars are
pretty top down and we're also going to
do a bottom-up thing and they funded
this grand challenge explorations thing
which is now supported more than a
thousand hundred-thousand-dollar grants
all around the world to stimulate
innovation on the parte young people on
the part of people in low and middle
income countries and many of these are
also transitioning to scale then the
next thing that happened was 2008 the
Grand Challenges Canada launch which I
mentioned then the next thing that
happened around 2010 was USAID the 20
billion dollar US aid agency kind of
also started to move into science and
technology and innovation and
development launched a number of
challenges including saving lives at
birth with which we in which we
participate and a number of other number
of other ones you see fighting Ebola
they came up with a protective suit that
was designed by a wedding dress designer
I mean this is really about sourcing
innovation which can come from anywhere
and also an open platform called the
global innovation fund so now it's
around 2010 you've got gates USAID Grand
Challenges Canada funding significant
hundreds of millions of dollars of
innovation in global health and
development but then something really
surprising happened that none of us
expected which is that the movement
spread across countries India launched a
Grand Challenges program Brazil did
China did recently Israel Peru Thailand
Ethiopia most recently Africa as a
regional platform and so what you see
now is a network of organizations around
the world supporting innovation in
global health in global development
producing the types of innovations I
showed you and the types that I
mentioned came out of the gates
foundation's program with more kind of
upstream science and technology that
will obviously take a while to come to
maturity and so what this is done is
really
to the equation from just supporting
scientists in low and middle income
countries which Grand Challenges Canada
has always been dedicated to doing those
hundred thousand dollar gates grants
were better at doing on the theory that
people close to the problem are good to
solve that problem shifted the game from
solving them to actually having domestic
government's support their own
scientists because all the aid money in
the world which is about a hundred and
thirty billion dollars a year of
official development assistance about 35
billion dollars a year of development
assistance associated with health that's
really not sufficient to solve the
global challenges we face so the other
sources of money you need our private
capital which judith rodin from the
Rockefeller Foundation's talked a lot
about in terms of how to mobilize as
impact investing and you need domestic
governments in low and middle income
countries to get skin in the game to
deal with issues of corruption to deal
with issues of taxation and start
investing in their own scientists and
that's really what this what this spread
shows we of course still have many
challenges I specifically showed you at
the beginning stories that are starting
to scale but even those things that are
reaching you know three hundred thousand
people hundreds of thousands or tens of
thousands of people that's still not
scale they're transitioning to scale but
real scale has only ever been pulled and
we have a real mentality in I think
innovation generally whether it's global
or domestic to push innovations we fund
them we support them we push them and we
don't pay enough attention to the demand
side demand of customers demand of
citizens demand of governments and
that's what we need to start to do and
you can see that this scaling ladder is
missing some rungs from proof-of-concept
getting towards impact in the fall along
with launching the sustainable
development goals the Secretary General
also launched the UN Secretary General
also launched the global strategy for
women children and adolescent health
I've been privileged to be a part of
that on the innovation side and in there
there's this thing called the every
woman every child innovation marketplace
that essentially is a laboratory to try
and break through some of these barriers
to transition to scale this is my last
slide before I open up for questions I
just wanted to take the stories I
mentioned some of the broader trends I
discussed not in a great level of detail
and adduced some lessons learned so what
have we learned in five years after 235
million dollars of input 700 projects
working with great partners like gates
and USAID and countries around the world
we've learned that you're really and
think about these as generalizable
things that apply well beyond public
health to your own business to your own
organization we've learned that when you
think about innovation you have to take
a very broad view of science and
technology social innovation business
and financial innovation and integrate
those for sustainability and scale and
you could see that coming out in the
stories we found that approaching this
through almost a venture capital like
approach of creating a big pipeline of
innovations i mentioned that out of
those seven hundred ninety percent or
proof of concept and ten percent are
transition to scale so we fund a lot of
100 to 250 thousand dollar things as
grants and then only about one in ten
fifty percent as grants fifty percent
actually is debt or equity to try and
improve the sustainability of those
situations and they're very different
questions when you're finding the
pipeline the question is is it a cool
idea and you'll hear some great stories
of students for example who are
developing social enterprises later
today that's the question at that stage
is this a cool idea and could at work
later on you've really got to focus in
like a venture capitalist on the
entrepreneur on the innovator do they
have the team that can scale we've
learned that the public and private
sector need to work together to really
achieve scale and you need to look at
issues in Grant finance and non grant
finance public and private finance and
this is sometimes touching an
ideological nerve in areas like public
health or in areas like the business
school you know the problems that I'm
talking about the challenges that I'm
discussing are way too big for any one
sector alone to solve and we need to
find ways to work together across
sectors one really important lesson is
the importance of embracing failure you
know if we fund
in 10 of the innovations at transition
to scale that we supported a proof of
concept it means we don't support ninety
percent of them now it turns out that
other people also support one in ten so
let's say one in five gets supported for
in five don't many of those also fail at
proof of concept and we've had to
develop a culture that actually embraces
failure it's kind of like the film meet
the robinsons you know let's say we'll
celebrate Louis for his terrific failure
you really need to be able to encourage
failure and risk-taking to succeed in
innovation the issue is not whether you
fail or not the issue is whether you
fail quickly for very little money and
you learn from it and if you have those
three conditions it's all good and we
should be embracing failure obviously
smart partners are important I already
talked about the issue of being able to
project outcomes that's the eight
million dollars live save 35 million
lives improved because in innovation we
often focus too much on the shiny
technological bauble or the new cool
thing and not enough on the impact and
if we focus on the impact sometimes we
focus on the outputs like the papers but
not the outcomes like the lives that are
improved like the ones I've shown you
and if you're doing innovation you have
to look not at the lives today but you
have to project forward because
innovation is about creating the future
so we've done some work there and then
finally the idea of reverse innovation
many of the issues that I've shown you
many of the innovations I've shown you
have really cool applicability in Canada
in the United States and elsewhere they
could serve to deflate the cost of care
and every single thing is set up to
prevent that in terms of established
professional systems established systems
even brands you know do you want a
really cool innovation from Zimbabwe
here at yale-new Haven you know so
there's tons of domestic potential here
too we often see people talking about
this reverse innovation rhetorically the
issue is to really slaw get out and do
it innovation by innovation obviously
want to thank Canada for this incredible
amount of support a terrific team
without whom
nothing obviously can be accomplished
and thank you very much for your
attention and again my main point was
just we have a global agenda for the
next 15 years that's something to which
Public Health can really contribute it's
something to which Yale in the School of
Public Health that actually across its
faculties can make an enormous
contribution innovation will be critical
that can be really fancy like putting
will backe into a mosquito so it doesn't
transmit dengue or it can be really
unfancied trained health worker on a
bench outside a clinic to reach 14,000
people whose lives otherwise would be
ruined fifty percent of whom you can
really now turn around so thank you very
much and I think we still have five six
seven minutes for questions discussion
really appreciate your
I really like this system it's a
terrific system they got here please hi
there my name is Nicole Poe scene so all
of these great innovations seem to hinge
on an aha moment or insight that tends
to be behavioral or our cultural are you
is your team employing social scientists
how are you coming to these social
scientists economists and how are you
having this sort of the kind of brain
trust obviously the culture of taking
risks but what else goes into finding
these insights yeah it's a really great
question so we're obviously a funder so
our job is to find innovators who
innovate and do things and right from
the beginning our chairman who actually
endowed the business school at the
University of Toronto got called Joe Rob
and said we're going to support not only
science and technology but also deeply
get into social innovation which of
course implicates the economist the and
that idea of different roads of
innovation leading to impact including
combining them together has been really
critical so just to endorse the kind of
transdisciplinarity underlying your
question we could talk about the tactics
of how we find them repetitive calls for
proposals on the same topic partnerships
with people like gates foundation is
really important in terms of in terms of
finding people but the main point I want
to make in response to your question is
that innovation can come from anywhere
and you it's your job it's our job to go
out and find it or to lay a table that
does not set barriers to entry so for
example I already gave you the example
of the USAID thing with the wedding
dress designer we also supported
something called the ode on device
through saving lives at birth with
partners like USAID and that was an
Argentinian car mechanic and the
Argentinian car mechanic saw this party
of taking a cork out of a wine bottle
and he said oh well that reminds me of
birth and I'm going to design node on
device which is a little balloon that
goes over the head of the baby to
deliver the baby and obstructed and
delayed labor the first innovation and
obstructed and delayed labor in hundreds
of years since forceps and vacuum
suction and so it's that kind of aha
moment that you talked about that can
come from anywhere young people you'll
hear a lot of them later this morning
and the job of an innovation funder is
to decrease the barriers to entry so
anyone with a great idea and it's often
people close to the problem who have
great ideas anyone with a great idea can
put that idea forward for testing so
thank you for the question hi David Lieb
shoots class of 80 thank you dr. singer
that was very inspiring my question for
you is the opposite of nicole's it's
about failure um how do you teach
prospective grantees to be comfortable
with failure when they obviously want to
succeed and have the aha moment and
scale-up and yet most of them won't how
do you do that you celebrate situations
of failure that led to better things so
for example we supported an innovator at
McGill University develop a tuberculosis
test with a particular type of
technology it didn't work he that was an
important finding people then don't
follow that path a week later his other
project on mystery patients gets three
million dollars from the Gates
Foundation so there's a personal
incentive actually not to pursue paths
that are not productive beyond even just
the the benefit to the field and you
have to emphasize that personal
incentive secondly we write up
situations like that and celebrate them
in our annual report so we don't publish
a report if here's 50 failures isn't
this fantastic but we feature failure
and celebrate it along with featuring
successes continuously make the point
thirdly you need to create that culture
in your own employees as a service
quality chain issue and fourthly you
just need to continue to emphasize and
celebrate and Maw
model because there's a kind of
anthropological element to this it's
almost a cultural issue and if you just
emphasize failure as actually cultural
value but the failure should be cheap
fast and you learn from it then it tends
to spread through the culture and I
think this is something that any
business can learn from and finally as a
machinery government issue it's hard to
fail within a government department or
agency and that's one of the reasons
that Grand Challenges Canada was kind of
set up if you will almost like an arm's
length foundation I can go around saying
failure is terrific as long as it's
cheap fast much harder for a deputy
minister or for a you know secretary of
transport and there are some areas
obviously you want to fail less like
transport much harder for someone inside
a government to do that so there's a
suite of measures I think to reinforce a
culture that failure is good if it meets
certain conditions Bob Mitchell most of
your stories seem to focus on women and
children what are the issues regarding
adult men and are they being addressed
and if so how why don't we take all
three questions and i'll respond to them
and then we'll save a little bit of time
adult men
yep and the third one of healthcare are
clean water and sustainable agriculture
and what are you doing towards that end
and can you give us a couple of examples
of your most successful projects great
so on the clean water thing i want to i
was very neglectful because i didn't
wish you a happy world toilet day and i
apologize for that and thank you for
reminding me so today is world toilet
day and you know one of the things we've
learned is and and I think Jeanette
mentioned this the social determinants
of health like sanitation like education
they are critical so we've actually
funded just to take sanitation as an
example for purposes of time because
sanitation is often more important than
the water at the other end you know
there's more than two billion people in
the world who don't have access to
sanitation sanitation is really the
underlying cause of this cycle of
diarrhea malnutrition child Mel
development so we funded about 25
innovations in sanitation less on the
tech side and more on the social
enterprise side gates foundation as a
complementary program where they've kind
of funded high-faluting toilets and
technological innovations in toilets and
so we funded a lot of social enterprises
that are delivering sanitation to the
bottom of the pyramid about 25 of them
at proof-of-concept about seven of them
at transition to scale just to use one
example there's a group called IDE in
Nepal that basically just clears up the
value chain if you're in Nepal and you
want to build a toilet you know the
plumber might show up one day this the
concrete guy a week later and it's hard
to get it all together so they've this
group is an NGO that's consolidated the
value chain so it kind of all gets done
at once and they're reaching about
500,000 people or will by the end of
their project with sanitation in Nepal
so just emphasize these issues of clean
water these issues of sanitation when
you break down what is a social
determinants of health it's Israel
receiving preschool
well it's sanitation social enterprises
reaching people it's focusing on child
development there is no greater cause of
inequality in the world then what
happens to kids brains in the first
thousand days of life and so all these
social determinants including sanitation
are really critical and we support them
because we have a broad view of global
health on the men's question there's a
lot of examples on an open platform our
strategy was to support three targeted
challenges saving lives at Birth saving
brains globe metal out but put about
fifty percent of our money into open
innovations so all throughout that
you've got issues of men's health kids
who died of malaria older men who are
depressed would be many of those
fourteen thousand the mental health
would go heavily into into men's health
infectious disease and and and so on so
a lot of examples of men but I get the
point of you know the particular focus
at the same time women have borne many
of the burdens and children and girls
have borne many of the burdens of
development and war and conflict and
those social determinants and so I don't
think we need to apologize for a
particular focus on those types of
communities and very vulnerable
communities like people with mental
health conditions may be the most
vulnerable in the world would have a
balance of would have a balance of women
and men on the reverse innovation
question it's a great question as I
mentioned everyone talks about it hard
to find examples you asked for examples
let me give you a couple in Botswana we
funded a new approach to the diagnosis
of childhood diarrhea so childhood
diarrhea kills about 600,000 children
every year along with pneumonia those
are the two communist infectious causes
of death of the six million children
under the age of five after the newborn
period and what you do now is if a child
has diarrhea if there's blood in the
stool then you treat with antibiotics if
there's no blood in the stool you don't
treat with antibiotics that's the World
Health Organization guideline what these
innovators did
was use a rectal swab that was actually
designed originally for lung samples to
take because the issue there is sample
collection if you imagine a baby with
diarrhea kind of hard to collect a
sample so you swab the baby's rectum and
then you can do a diagnostic test for
the cause of the diarrhea they're
finding in Zimbabwe was one-third of the
time you discover a bug that will change
your treatment compared to that
guideline of empirical therapy with with
blood a huge finding and they did a
small randomized trial that actually
showed that that approach the diagnosis
of diarrhea also improved the linear
growth of children which is a huge
finding so they have now been funded
this group by the Government of Canada
to work in northern Canada in the Yukon
I think to bring this same kind of
technology and diagnosis of diarrhea to
Aboriginal communities where there's
remote issues so there's one concrete
example and to test it there where
there's a very high expense of flying
kids who are sick out so you want to
prevent them from getting sick so
there's a concrete example that I'm
aware of second concrete example that is
just getting underway is hearing
screening so you don't think about
things like disability hearing vision
ambulation you don't really think about
those as global health problems but
there's tons of people around the world
who have problems of the disability in
those domains impairing their ability to
function employability and lives there's
a social enterprise as we found it quite
a bit of hearing but that's another area
where a combination of hearing screening
social enterprises and low-cost hearing
aids developed for low and middle-income
countries are starting to be used in
northern aboriginal populations you've
got real difficulty in this area though
real barriers so for example in
Aboriginal health the primary dictum is
nothing about us without us so there's
some which is obviously something I
support strong governance issues in
terms of reverse innovation on the cost
de-escalation side you see I didn't
really give you many examples of that
every barrier is set up to prevent that
the silo ization of different types of
government funding the professional
organizations who actually don't want
you know one dollar ophthalmology
implants when you can charge a hundred
dollars or whatever for an ophthalmology
implant in the case of cataracts and so
there's those professional barriers
their branding barriers I mentioned and
if you're looking for something to break
through on as an innovator yourself this
is an area that if you focused on very
significantly and you went to the
pipeline of a few thousand innovations
that were developed for low and
middle-income country settings so
they're being innovated at low price
points with good distribution models and
you worked really hard on bringing those
back into the United States that would
be a way to make a ton of money because
you'd be able to and provide much better
care to people because you'd be able to
provide at a much lower cost a suite of
services that that that reach equivalent
health outcomes so that's a way for the
future for us as opposed to you know
those poor people out there there's a
lot that we can learn from the south and
a lot that we can learn for innovation
targeted to the south and and you asked
for two concrete examples I gave you two
concrete examples but I want to
highlight that systematically everything
in the system in in our systems in our
health systems our innovation systems is
actually set up against taking these
really exciting low-cost innovations and
bringing them and maybe the place to end
which is the segue to Paul is if there's
any group that will be able to break
through that particular barrier I know
we haven't been able to in a systematic
way it will be our students and Paul's
going to talk i'm sure a lot about
students students are the disruptive
force in a very positive sense in in a
society and you know maybe this is
something Paul that the Yale School of
Public Health should do launched a
reverse innovation Grand Challenge
targeted at students and you really use
the somebody likes it up there but
they're not aren't you supposed to be
standing up but
you know so I just really want to say
and we've learned this in innovation
generally and it should be obvious that
it's groups like young people that will
break through barriers like the one I
described and I didn't describe a story
of success on reverse innovation I
described a barrier that we're facing
and a story of kind of failure at the
moment but if there's anyone that can
break through the failure its our
students and Paul's going to talk about
them now thank you very much it's a
great privilege to be here
you